southwest medical wants to remind the
community about the importance of infant
immunization so i spoke with one of
their doctors
to learn more check it out so coming up
later this month it's infant
immunization
week and we're talking about the
importance of infant
immunization so let's start with that
what do you what are your thoughts
yes so immunizations is one of the most
important ways that we can protect
children
from preventable childhood diseases and
even though we may not realize it
a lot of things that we take for granted
now a lot of diseases that used to be
pretty rampant here in the united states
and around the world
have been minimized because of
immunizations
and because of that i think parents
don't understand the
significance of immunizations because we
don't see these diseases as much anymore
but we've learned that when immunization
rates go down
these diseases can pop back up which is
really important to emphasize again why
it's important to immunize your child
on time and regularly according to the
schedule recommended by the american
academy of pediatrics and the cdc
which vaccinations do you think children
actually need
so this really depends on the age of the
child right now we are
basically protecting kids from more than
14 of
preventable diseases through
immunizations so it's important to know
based on your child's age and their
current immunization status
to talk with their doctor to find out
what they need
whether it is for their child early
childhood immunizations
or for what they need to go to school
and day care and this is very important
that they are up to date especially if
they're going to be in a setting with
other kids the whole reason they're
given these
immunizations at this early age is that
younger children are more vulnerable
to these childhood infections so if
you're waiting until your child gets
older
the risk of them actually acquiring the
disease is when they're younger
and these vaccines have been tested over
the years for safety
and it's really important to note that
you are really preventing some very
serious complications
not just children but preteens
teens and adults should also see what
their immunization status is
now we know adults have the opportunity
to get the coveted vaccine which is
highly recommended for everyone who's
able to get it which is wonderful
soon they'll be releasing data on
coveted vaccinations for
teenagers too and we're eagerly waiting
to see
what the ctc says about that but it is
important to get updated on those shots
and certain immunizations such as for
pertussis or whooping cough
the teenagers do need to get their
booster dose to continue that protection
and adults do too so it's not something
that just stops
at childhood it continues on throughout
your years and
into adulthood southwest medical has
locations across
southern nevada just call
or 702-877-5199 smalv.com for more